hi GQ what's up it's Joe Jonas here I'm
going to go undercover from my home on
the Internet this is actually me pora
we're going to Korra hmm this says it's
from stuffy turner did joe jonas and
sophie turner really get married by an
Elvis impersonator in Las Vegas oh I
think this is the forum sophie Turner
I'm just gonna imagine my wife wrote
this sophie Turner yes we did get
married in Vegas by a Elvis impersonator
we have to get legally married in the
States so we thought it'd be really fun
to get all of our friends invite them
out and do an impromptu wedding and we
actually had some people that I didn't
really even know that well there some
peoples like I'm now closer with but
Khalid was there that was pretty cool
and Diplo decided the live stream the
whole thing so thank for that Diplo and
with putting dog filters in our face
it's great it kind of blew up in our
faces because my parents called me the
next morning and they were like did you
just get married and I realized I told
everybody but I forgot to tell my
parents so kids out there make sure you
tell your parents when you're getting
legally married posted is Joe Jonas
allergic to spaghetti hell no yeah I
love spaghetti and we've been making a
lot of pasta dishes during this
quarantine I'm not still in a penicillin
I'm allergic to and shellfish I guess
you could say I'm allergic to shellfish
spaghetti next how does Joe Jonas get
along with his brothers well we've
learned to put family first and that's
been really important for us and also
we've learned to respect you and each
other needs some time and we have our
own separate lives so I think at this
point we really missed the crap out of
each other it's been so long since I've
seen these guys on tour we always try to
take like an hour out of our day just to
spend time together and it reminds us
why we're doing this and whether if it's
working out having a meal or just taking
a walk a bike ride or something and
seeing a city I think that's helpful for
people when they work together and it's
always the same thing every day posted
Twitter
Joe is Kim Nick is Courtney and Kevin is
Khloe yes or no duh
thank you hats bud with eight DS at
Jonas WFT ah she didn't get WTF
unfortunately but has Sophie gotten sick
and tired of Joe being around 24/7 I'm
assuming you're speaking about the
quarantine we haven't gotten sick of
each other yet we're actually enjoying
our time together
we're always on tour for so long 90 some
cities and she was filming elsewhere so
to actually be together and have this
couple times important but I have to ask
her
Sophie am i annoying you will go with
yet what is your favorite song to
perform love you Joe Jonas by the way
love you too Krystal I'm assuming it's
speaking about one of ours the brother
songs I really enjoy singing hesitate it
means a lot to me but in general many
rivers to cross is one of my favorites
it's a classic and I like singing that
sometimes of our songs but just for fun
submit more Quora who has better vocals
Nick Jonas or Joe Jonas I mean that
really is dealer's choice here I think
Nick has a fantastic voice I think Kevin
where's Kevin here huh next what are
some less known facts about Joe Jonas I
have Vanilla Ice's cell phone number and
occasionally I like to crank the phone
call so now you know I said that was me
all these times now we're gonna go to
IMDB let's see what they got to say
nicknames jo JJ DJ danger yeah I guess
that's kind of correct there's other
nicknames that I have I mean when I was
in middle school I joined the new school
and apparently there was too many Joe's
in the school so this one kid decided
that my new name should be JJ Jonas
which makes no sense
so JJ Jonas we can add that to that
nickname list before becoming a musician
he wanted to become a comedian actually
in cup of joe I went on stage being
encouraged by Tina Fey to go do some
standup
advice for me was go on stage and tell
the truth the truth is always funny so I
try my best
I've really enjoyed it I want to
continue it I feel like everybody should
try it at least once in their life the
nerves that you feel it's really scary
but rewarding if you get one laughs next
fan of Britney Spears I like that that's
there that is true my first CD I ever
bought myself was at a 7-eleven and it
was a pretty Spears album posted now
we're gonna go to Instagram Instagram
always has really fun trolling comments
let's see what we got to find all right
I shaved my face Quarantine beard it's
no more slowly growing back Brenda hi
Mille fard burn hi Maillard how does he
manage to have a baby face just like
that I mean what's his skincare routine
I have to be honest I do have a filter
on this picture that builder did a lot
of good to me in this photo yeah I've
washed my face little facial fuel make
sure to moisturize and my wife likes
popping any zit that might be on my face
she calls them spots so if I pop a zit
or a spot without her knowing she's very
bad next all right this is a post I did
about the concert film that we just
released cni pop five eight eight that
says wow you guys definitely means
something to all of us great documentary
with I think those are Welling eyes I
have a question when they make your guys
Hollywood documentary because I can
totally see this happening what actor
would you like to see played each of you
that's great and I can answer for my
brothers I think that's I think
obviously Matthew McConaughey should
play me you know I think Kevin deserves
the rock and Nic Mark Wahlberg because
actually they kind of look alike if Nick
has a backwards hat and the tank top he
looked almost exactly like Mark Wahlberg
okay ready right it's really fun I love
reddit Emily this is the look I
genuinely thought Joe Jonas was gonna
see me wear and fall in love with me too
that's innate oh that's great I mean it
is a strong look and the pose that's
really key
looking good Emily keep it up submit
we're going back to Twitter all right
this is from Breanna is locked up with a
pretty cool font unlocked up how many
LEGO sets have you completed Joe Wow
that's a tough question there are quite
a few LEGO sets stranger things set two
of the Hogwarts castle sets we also have
a few Lord of the Rings we also have a
roller coaster that we want to finish
I'm always confused if it's Lego or
Legos but I think it's correct the way
you said it which is just Lego like Lego
posted this is from K Jonas what was
your favorite spot in the UK Joe from
the cup of joe series my favorite thing
to do when I was in London I took a
penalty kick at a professional soccer
stadium or as they would say football
stadium and that was really exciting for
me I actually got it in the net on a
third try and I would like to believe
the guy was actually trying his best but
I don't know I think he was going easy
on me submit how different would the
world be if Joe Jonas have been cast as
Captain America instead of Chris Evans
oh I think the world would be a lot
different probably Chris would be a lead
singer of a band of brothers and I would
be carrying my shiny shield around the
world saving the day this is from Tyler
the question is at Joe Jonas do you
still have this outfit you better
believe I do what do you think I'm
wearing below here huh
very comfortable next this is from Liz
biz oh wait here's my question for later
this is for Nick Joe and Kevin what are
some things that you guys do to keep
busy during this quarantine this is my
new favorite thing is zoom beer pong and
I really encourage everyone to try you
set up the cups closest to the camera so
that's the other players cups that makes
any sense
probably just google and find out the
instructor is way better than me all
right we're going to YouTube let's check
it out
this is a compilation video this is the
best of Sophie and Joe I'd actually like
to watch this and this person asks hey
Joe what's your favorite food and drink
I like that they assumed I was just
gonna go into this and watch this and
comment that but I am actually doing it
now I do like a tequila soda I have to
say I'd like my brothers to kill a lot
I'm not even a part of the company so
this is not a shameless plug here this
is a family plug Villa one is delicious
and my favorite food I'm allergic to
spaghetti so I can't eat that but I do
like I'll go with pasta lasagna posted
more from IMDB he has German English
Scottish Irish Italian Sicilian from a
great grandfather french-canadian and
Cherokee Native American ancestry well
that's how do they know all this I don't
think it's Scottish is correct I don't
think it's french-canadian and things
French unless somebody liked took a
glass that I was drinking and swab dit
and then sent this in and you actually
know what my ancestry actually is
alright moving on
collected GI Joe action figures and pens
as a child I'm always so curious how
people find this information out and
this is on IMDB such a weird place for
this information to be I don't think
this will help me at all get a movie
role or TV show but maybe GI Joe will
call one day I did collect GI Joes and I
collected a lot of Pokemon cards I was
more of a fan of Pokemon than getting a
girl's number because I remember when I
was younger the prettiest girl in school
had a really rare card I tricked her
into switching for a really unreal
target favorite movie is School of
scoundrels Wow this is dated we need to
update this
it's favorite band is Switchfoot that I
do love Switchfoot but this is obviously
from a long time ago his favorite
singers Jonny Lang I like Jonny Lang I
think currently my favorite movie I'll
go with Back to the Future one actually
I think two is actually better than one
I also think home alone two is better
than one I think all the threes were
pretty okay I liked Switchfoot but we
will update that too you know I I love
cold plates new albums go with Coldplay
his favorite singers Johnny lang
his favorite singer I'll go is Frank
Sinatra but I like Jonny Lang to submit
well that's it and that was fun I hope
your questions have been answered
correctly or to your satisfaction
signing off the internet
you